Destiny of an Emperor, Fulfill an Ancient Prophecy.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
And we all hope to die in the same hour of the same day of the same year.
And we're making that pact right now on the podcast.
Right, guys? Yes. Not only do I hope it, I vow it.
I will make sure that if I'm ever about to die, I will find you guys and take you down with me.
I think that's sort of what it sounds like, doesn't it?
It's sort of like a suicide pact.
And I don't really know what that's really supposed to tell you about someone's, like, confidence in the mission of Nostalgia.
It depends if I'm like, wow, Sean is going to greatly outlive me.
Like, I definitely want to make that pact.
And I'll ride, you know, ride your coattails to the long life.
But it sounds like they expect to die in battle if it happens to be at the same hour of the same day of the same year.
Like, they plan to fail.
Yeah, I think, well, see, I think that I could take it as like, all right, the three of us are going into battle.
And like, if you're going to die, I'm not like backing down from that.
I will fight with you until the end.
That's basically what it feels like to me.
That's very poetic.
I like that one better.
I'm going to make sure that I outlive both of you.
Good luck. When you hear the title, Destiny of an Emperor, I don't know about you guys, but I was expecting one of those Koei Grand Strategy games.
This is an RPG from Capcom.
With like the flavorings of one.
Like it basically is the story of a Grand Strategy game that we have played.
Maybe Joe didn't.
Yeah, isn't this Romance of the Three Kingdoms?
Yeah, this is Romance of the Three Kingdoms, the book.
I guess this is sort of like, you know, like the Peter Jackson Lord of the Rings and like the Ralph Bakshi Lord of the Rings, but it's just Romance of the Three Kingdoms.
It, yeah, it's interesting that we're getting two vastly different takes on the source material here.
And it's funny, I know you asked Joe if he, maybe, maybe he didn't play that one.
That is, of course, because Joe is not usually present for the Koei episodes.
But, uh, that's just a coincidence.
I was present for one. Right, it's just a coincidence.
It's just a coincidence. Yeah, yeah, I swear.
Joe, Joe, while we have you, maybe you would like to kind of set the stage here of just like, you know, we had Romance of the Three Kingdoms as a grand strategy game, as a Nobunaga style.
And we always go back to Nobunaga because that was the first one we dealt with.
It's a great thing to say. It just feels like great out of the mouth, you know?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Nobunaga and, uh, that's some of the children's first words, I'm sure.
Uh, maybe, maybe you want to just tell us a little bit about how that kind of game could be translated into an RPG.
Well, I am, if you're asking how it could be translated and maybe how this game attempted it.
How this game translated it, yes.
I can do that.
Um, you know, it took, it's, on the surface it's very different than like a Final Fantasy or a Dragon Warrior, but the more you look at it, it's, um, at a, you know, bird's eye view, it's, uh, it's similar.
But what it basically does is you play as these, uh, what are they, generals?
Warlords. Yeah. Warlords.
Um, and you, you wander the map as you're, as you're taking on other warlords and recruiting them.
But instead of, uh, instead of being like your one character with HP, you're one warlord with soldiers and your soldiers are your HP.
So like it kind of, but really that's what it is.
Your soldiers are your HP.
No, no, no, it just made me think of like, and the bones are their money, but.
And they've got like tactics, which is kind of their way of getting magic into the, the game.
And they, they have everything that you expect in like a classic JRPG is kind of here, but translated to, you know, with the, with the help of your imagination, you're what you're, you're watching large scale battles of armies unfold rather than four characters fighting for goblins or something.
And I, I like that recontextualization of like HP and like, instead of magic, you're, you're, you're deploying tactics, but it, it's kind of half-hearted because you go to an inn and it has three beds.
And it's like, does your whole army just sleep in this inn?
Is it like a massive Amazon warehouse of an inn or, um, are we three adventurers?
And maybe this was like old assets from something they were working on.
That was more traditional. Uh, and then you have like, you could buy items and just like, Oh, here's a robe or like buying a, are you buying 3000 robes?
Because like the food is a, it's a high number.
Like that makes sense.
Everything else is kind of really abstracted.
Yeah. I, I, I definitely, uh, saw that.
And I guess, I guess the optimist in me was more like, well, you know, this is just trying to be abstract ways to represent like the, the health of your army.
But the more like you describe it, you're kind of right.
Like you're, the food is, the food is not like, Oh, buy a loaf of bread.
It's like buy 30,000 food.
You know? So like, it does like the more you mentioned, like it probably is that they just like, well, okay, we're not going to like figure out all these little things.
We'll just keep those all generic and, um, and just change like some of the context.
But I, I mean, I was able to play it and kind of imagine it as like, yeah, I'm, I'm plussing up this warlord and therefore his, his soldiers are being plussed up too.
But yeah. Yeah. It's interesting that you, you know, mentioned the rice and food system and the HP thing.
Cause I think those are the two things that set this apart from the dragon warriors and the final fantasies where yes, the actual like turn-based combat plays very similar, but the, the food thing specifically is very reminiscent of those, uh, Koei grand strategy games, because those always have like, you always have to make sure you have enough rice or else you're going to, you know, have an unhappy civilization.
Or you have to like feed your army and stuff that counts as something in addition to the HP of the game where every step you take basically is like consuming food.
And then you go into the, the towns and battle and stuff as ways to get additional resources.
And it's not something you can, you know, like constantly have to be managing.
It's not like a survival simulator, but it is something that you have to keep in mind as you're playing the game of never, uh, being without too much food, because then you'll start taking damage essentially because your troops are dying.
And again, your troops are your HP, but your troops being your HP plays into the combat side of things too, because that is how, uh, your attack power is determined in this game.
Believe it or not, your, how much damage you do is indicated by how healthy your army is at the scale of a power to the power of 10.
So I'll say that I didn't even realize that, but that, that makes sense.
That does make it like, yeah, that makes it mean more.
They did put more thought into that element of it where it's like, yeah.
It's more than just saying like, oh, it's not HP, it's people.
Yeah. It's not just a reskin of HP.
It's like, no, these are your people.
And if you don't have as many of them, you're not going to hit as hard because, you know.
Right, right, right. It's not just like a numbers game where it's like, well, I just want to have more so this way I can outlast the enemy.
It's like, I actually do more damage, but I did mention that it's a power of 10 thing.
So it does kind of become a game of optimization, especially in the battles where essentially if you have, uh, uh, a hundred troops, let's say.
So your HP is 100.
The second you drop to 99, now you've dropped from a power of 10.
So your damage is now different from 0 to 99, 100 to 999, uh, 1,000 to 9,999.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like, it's not like, oh, it does an exact calculation of I have 271 troops and this is my damage output.
But the, uh, an army slash character that has 998 hits just as hard as one with 101.
Yes. Oof.
And so, yes, exactly.
And so what happens is, is you wind up, uh, not even in your own battles, of course, but, uh, the battles, uh, that, you know, the enemies you encounter, you start looking at, well, who's got the most troops, right?
Like some of the, some of the ones that are just generically labeled rebel force all have like at the early part of the game, they have like a hundred troops each or whatever.
And then one of them has, or sorry, no, they have less than a hundred.
They have 25. And then the main general has a hundred.
Well, I should start taking him out first to make sure he's just as weak as his rebel forces.
And so it just kind of becomes a game of balancing numbers, uh, rather than like strategically thinking about who you should attack because there's not classes.
There's just size of armies to think about.
So you were playing a lot.
I mean, I guess, yeah. So I guess this, this, uh, begs us to kind of go into like the actual like moment to moment of these battle of these battles, because there's a couple of ways to play them.
Um, and the way you're describing is sort of the more micromanagey, uh, this can take you 10 minutes way to, in a single battle, um, way of fighting.
And then there's also like the, the, like all out, which is good for just like random encounters.
Um, like essentially an auto battle system, right?
Yeah. Well, I, I get, I don't even know if, cause you're not really like, you're not creating any tactics.
You're just, you're just throwing these two masses of people together.
Um, if you select all out and, and without any like management at all.
And then there's the one where it's like more final fantasy slash dragon warrior, where you're selecting each thing you're going to do.
But that like takes forever.
So I just wanted to do auto battle for everything.
Yeah. And I guess the happy medium there, which thankfully they do allow for it in the game is that you can all out at any time.
So the best way to play the game is essentially to first take your strongest guys and whittle down, uh, you know, the largest, uh, enemies, the largest sized enemies on the screen.
And then once they're all kind of below a certain damage input, now you can do all out and you'll just kind of know that like you're going to be doing larger damage than they are.
And you don't have to worry about necessarily, uh, any of your characters getting a, you know, a knockout or anything like that.
So it's a little bit of both.
And I do agree with you that, uh, it sometimes is like, especially with the random encounter system, if you're just running into like five V five, like it is a lot to ask to just continue to use battling and tactics.
When all out is just there to kind of do the same exact thing.
And you're probably just going to rush back to the town and sleep at the end.
Cause you've got more than enough gold in one battle to sleep your entire army of thousands of people.
So maybe it should have had more of a like trade off for that.
But I found myself just basically, uh, random battling a lot, waiting till I was weak enough, going back to the end, sleeping, and then just continuing with my all out attacks.
Except for obviously, uh, this game has large, yeah.
Large story moments too, where you have to take on specific generals.
And as Joe mentioned, you have the ability to, uh, then recruit those generals.
You recruit so many characters in this game.
It's, it's nuts.
I've heard of RPGs where like, you know, you can have 90 people, uh, join your party or whatever over the course of the game.
And I feel like this comes close to that.
Like, I don't know exactly how many people you get, but even just in the very first town, you already have your team of three.
And then you immediately just get two other guys to, to join your party just by talking to them.
You can completely miss them if you don't talk to them, but they'll just be like, Hey, we want to join the fight.
And then they do. And then just as easily they can die in the battle too.
And that's the end of that.
Yeah. I mean, I mean, you can obviously, you can bring them back, but yes,
but I kind of like to play it.
I mean, just because it was different to play it that way.
Whereas as long, as long as the people, you know, weren't my like main, uh, characters that I was using like that, that I needed.
I was sometimes I was like, well, you know, I just recruited these other people.
So it's like, okay, I'll just canonically.
I lost this character in his army.
Like they fell in battle, but now I recruit these other people.
Huh? More blood for the blood guard.
Yeah. But no, but like, it's interesting.
Cause it's like a, it's like a, a reason to try out new, um, party members.
And, uh, I, I will say that, uh, I did notice by doing that a lot.
And, and I, I confirmed this by, uh, reading a little bit online, uh, which is never wrong.
So definitely confirmed that a lot of these, um, like these like lesser warlords are, they cannot get to the levels of some of the ones that the developers want to be like your mains.
So like some of them, like, just no matter what you do, will never be as strong as like the ones that they intended to be the ones you were using.
That makes sense.
And what I read online, you know, based on like the story and, and I know the story is based in like somewhat, uh, some semblance of history, you know, sure.
You're, you know, obviously like just inspired by or whatever, but like, yeah, there are like, there are generals that they're just like, yeah, this, this guy would never be, he's not the hero of the story.
And he's like, he's like a low general and they didn't want the player to be able to like go against cannon that far.
Yeah. You, you bring up a good point, Joe.
It's nuts that it's not just like, here's a 150, I don't know.
I'm making it up, but like, here's 150 people that you can have join your party, but they're all just kind of the same warrior class with the same stats.
It's like, no, they actually did take the time to like give them all individual, like intelligence stats, strength stats, defense stats.
So that you could make a use case for, uh, you know, like, oh, here's the optimal party.
But then like, you know, if you don't recruit this guy or you don't encounter this guy or, uh, you don't want to use this kind of thing, you can also go this way.
Like we were talking about how the strength of final fantasy is that you can make, uh, a team of four, but of any kind of different classes in here, you can have like any, like, I couldn't even imagine.
I don't know how, I don't know the names of my characters cause I wasn't really looking at it that hard, but like, I can't imagine that the three of us were running the same team, you know, like that's how, that's how many characters you run into.
And you have to pick like, who's going to be your, um, is it tactician?
Is it general? Like there, there's one you have to pick to, I forget what they called it.
Yeah. So you have to pick one to be your tactician and you know, you could just like assign that to your strongest thinking that that's the way to go.
But really it's like the one with the, um, uh, intelligence, the highest intelligence to be able to, because, because there's a weird thing about the magic system, which again, is just the tactics.
But there are, uh, tactics points.
So instead of MPTP, but then there's also a MTP for your max tactical points as like a party.
And so you have to put the best, like you have to put the strongest person in that position to be the tactician to max out the MTPs.
This way everybody can use their TP.
It's, it's a little less complicated than I'm making things sound.
And I just want to say that about this game overall is that when we talk about it for an episode and we just talk about the, uh, the systems and the kind of the unique things this game is doing, it might sound like this is a game that completely reinvents RPGs, but we are just highlighting the stuff that like stands out.
The more you don't, the more you, you know, just go in the overworld and have the random encounter experience and go to the shops, the more that you start to realize, like this game is as complicated as you want to make it sound.
Like you can, to Sean's point earlier, just use all out attack and get by and not really have to think too much about strategy or tactics.
outside of bosses at least outside of bosses sure sure but you could also just grind to hell right
like you could just level up enough that the bosses aren't that big of a problem that's what
it sounds like you did no no no i followed a guide actually very carefully because i got my ass handed
to me by those same bosses and was like i think i need to find out how to play this game so there
was a great uh there was many actually on game faqs many guides uh i followed the one that's
always highest rated and using that guide like i gotta tell you it's just it's weird how many times
this game can surprise you and then go back to basics like right after that you know like there's
like oh wow that wasn't expecting that like you recruit so many people just by talking to them or
defeating them in battle and then all of a sudden you got to make sure you have a horse for this one
guy otherwise you can't recruit him and it's like whoa that's that's like almost like a side quest
slash story element slash missable character thing that all the steed does i couldn't i never yes
yeah yes that is um and it's just funny that like you have those moments so this game to me kind of
kept me on my toes but also managed to bore me a little bit in the moment because like what you
were just describing before and what led me to believe that you sort of played this via grinding
uh was like oh yeah you just go and you fight a bunch of bandits and you go home and then you
you sleep and you come back and you fight a bunch of bandits and it's like that's kind of what it feels
like and there's really no appreciable difference in how a battle plays out aside from it being harder
between a boss and the random battle enemies it's even like it could be just as tedious because
these random battles can have five forces at once and the the more story bosses can have five uh like
armies at once and you're kind of doing the same thing and you really have to love the the battle
system in this game to love this game i think yeah yeah because i think that it has its its pluses like i i do
actually really i don't think there was ever a boss battle that i didn't have fun with you know i
enjoyed the boss battles because you know it's never gets like super complicated strategy but because of
the way that i don't know just because of like something about it is like a little different than
another jrpg and you know as i'm saying that i'm realizing that i don't know exactly what it is
but you know i guess it's just that i felt a lot more um like inclined to like mike was saying
earlier lower the to like target the the strong forces lower their to equalize things enough where
then i could go all out you know and i guess you don't have to play it that way but because i'm
playing that way it does it does make it feel different and i and i was enjoying kind of coming
up with that strategy the problem is all the other battles that aren't boss battles where you don't
have to do that yes it gives you that quality of life command of all out where you can just kind of
watch them go at it and watch your army take them out but even that takes kind of long like not
anywhere near as long as doing a whole battle but like you can do a lot of random encounters in this
game so like for that to be happening over and over again just for you to watch numbers go down
that part does get i guess what one other thing that i think uh adds to the flavor of the game and
might just be satisfying for a certain kind of player is unlike a lot of jrpgs uh there is just a
there's a lot of transparency of information uh like where you see each health bar it almost it's
almost like a just a fighting game in some ways like where each enemy has its health bar and if
you're doing all out you see it tick down or if you're doing the more tactical mode um you're still
seeing that visible uh okay i'm actually doing damage whereas in a final fantasy or a dragon warrior
yada yada uh you're just seeing your attacks are hitting you don't know how close to death your enemy
is i think that can add some satisfaction to it it's funny that when you do finally stop doing
the all-out battles and have to do these uh quote-unquote boss battles or just like more
personalized fighting approaches and then you get into the tactics of things there was that moment
uh where like you know a lot of rpgs are like this is the heal spell this is the fire spell right
like and you just it's called fire or it's called cure and you're like yeah i know exactly what that
does because i played other rpgs and i'm gonna use it now this game doesn't have that at all going for
it and required me to constantly keep checking back with the guide to be like okay and this spell does
what again like it's they're just you know i'm not i'm sure that they actually do translate well it's
just that because they're it's all chinese yeah it's all chinese right and not chinese uh typeface
of course it's it's um it's in english yeah it's like phonetic yeah phonetically it it just becomes
challenging to to remember that no matter how many times because they aren't like labeled or anything
my rule of thumb was that if i select it and then i can target an enemy uh that that means oh big damage
time and if i couldn't do that then like oh this is just like a buff or something yeah later on
i was gonna say later on you get you get other things that you can do to the enemies other than deal
damage um like lower their stats yeah yeah and i did like start to by sight only like recognize certain
spells that i used more of or spells tactics that i used more often where it was like yeah there was one
that like that like increases your your resistance or or your defense and there was another one that
uh heals you obviously like that one i used a lot so like i started to recognize it by sight but if you
asked me what they were right now i couldn't tell you but like give me the exact list in the exact order
i was looking at them i can point out which ones which that's a testament to how often you use them
which is great right
soそれではそれではそれではそれではそれではそれではそれではそれではそれでは!!!
Is there another time period
that you would like to see
the destiny of an emperor treatment done to,
where you're playing as historical figures
in a very gamified setting?
The American Revolution.
I had a feeling.
Only because I'm playing Assassin's Creed 3 right now.
The whole time I'm playing it, I'm like,
wow, nothing is ever set here, ever.
That's why I'm like, wow, this is so interesting
how battles worked.
I'm sure that this game wouldn't really give me
quite the history of how muskets work and everything.
I think it would be funny to make the JRPG version
of the American Revolution,
like going around as George Washington.
Yeah. See, but the British would attack the way that you do
in Destiny of an Emperor,
where you have like X amount of troops as your HP,
and you deal a lot of damage all at once,
and you got to whittle that down.
But then the Americans would have some kind of guerrilla warfare
mechanics built into theirs,
where they can just kind of spread out
and not have to do the traditional war games.
And I think that would be a noteworthy thing to make that stand out
from Destiny of an Emperor. I like the question, Sean, I kind of feel like just in general,
so many RPGs are either fantasy or sci-fi that I'm just down for,
not even just Destiny of an Emperor,
but I'm just down for more historical RPGs as a thing.
Forget about this system being forced onto it.
Just like, let's get our World War II RPGs with decision-making trees
so that we can alter the course of history.
Let's get that. If I may make a recommendation,
and I may have mentioned this in a previous episode,
but Expeditions Rome is a game that starts out,
unlike this, which is, you know,
you are the historical figure in question,
and while it is not, you know, accurate,
it's still doing its best to cover the broad strokes of what's going on.
That game starts out with Caesar dying as, like, a young dude,
and now you are in, like, his position,
and you can sort of choose to do things that he may have done
or go a different way.
It's very much what you kind of described.
So I would have looked that up.
It's a lot of fun. It's a turn-based RPG, but, like, tactical.
I like it. I'm going to mention some other things
that I noticed about this game
that don't quite fit under any kind of category,
but if, you know, if you guys want to react to them
or bring up things of your own as I mentioned this,
I feel like this is that section now
for just, like, cool little quirks in the game.
One that I really liked is that,
so obviously you can only have a team of five at any given point,
but you have to kind of, like,
you can put them in the reserves or whatever
so that you can call them back later,
and you can also have the ability to fire people,
like, basically just let them go.
And if you let them go,
you can then find them in random battles again
and have to fight them
because now they don't,
they're not part of your army.
And I don't know, that's just, like,
that's something that I didn't think would be possible
in a game like this.
Like, you release,
it's like releasing your Pokemon
and having the ability to, like,
run into them in the wild again.
Yeah. With, like, the nickname you gave them and everything,
still in the wild. Yes, yeah.
I like it. Yeah, I like that.
What's a warlord to do other than warlord?
Right. But, you know,
that kind of brings up another thing
that we didn't really mention
is that some of these random encounters
you come across in the world
are these other characters.
Whether they're bosses that you'll fight later,
bosses that you've already fought,
like, they are roaming the world,
quote unquote. And depending on their status in the story,
usually if you beat them,
you can request that they convert
and, like, join you.
And sometimes they'll do it for money,
sometimes they'll just do it,
like, because you defeated them,
and other times they'll refuse.
But, like, that is a way
that you could pick up new, um,
companions and new party members.
And also, now their armies
won't be roaming around,
and that'll kind of lessen
the amount of, um,
random encounters in that area.
So, like, there's a lot going on
in this game that we have not seen
in other games that, like,
that I also did not think was possible
back, uh, you know, in 1990.
And then in a lot of RPGs,
when you start, uh,
you have to buy all your equipment
in the first town
with, like, some gold
that either the king gets you
or you find in a chest
or you just start with.
Uh, in this game,
you have equipment on you
at the start of the game,
but... Oh, God, yeah.
It's unequipped.
Yeah. Why do I have to equip
the equipment that's already
on my persons?
That was weird,
because, yeah, I remember in the first battle
that I got into,
uh, I was just exploring
the menus and went into items,
like, oh, I wonder if I start with any items,
and I'm like, oh, cool, a flail.
I, maybe I can just
throw this at them?
Like, is that a, is this a throw game?
And I selected,
and it's like, yeah, you can't use that
right now. And then was just like,
well, this, this game is really,
like, I'm very weak.
And then later realized
that I could equip them.
So it's, that, I don't know what
that decision was.
The long play for this game
is at 11 hours,
which, uh, it feels long.
I'm sure it's even way
longer than that if you don't know
exactly what you're doing.
I'm sure this could be
the kind of game that you could sing,
uh, as, as high as,
like, maybe 40 hours into.
Like, there are a lot
of different chapters
and different, like,
twists and turns in the story,
and just, the, the world map
is very large.
Uh, the game,
the game has a lot of,
uh, a lot of depth
to its story
and, uh, the kind of
character relationships.
But, in any kind of game
that's that long,
uh, eventually, the numbers that you saw
in the beginning of the game,
uh, become, like, trivial.
And so, uh,
in the let's play,
at the end of it, like, the,
you start with, like, a hundred HP
as your, like, troops.
Mm-hmm. This person has
26,719,
22,500,
11,000. It's like, what do those numbers
mean at this point?
Like, everybody's numbers
just get really big.
All their stats get really big.
The, the food is at,
uh, 6,955,000.
It's like, what is going on?
Uh, but,
you gotta appreciate
that kind of stuff, too. Yeah, I, I've definitely
felt the, um,
the, like,
power creep, I guess,
even in, in,
you know, it's sort of the first
quarter of the game,
which is, you know, I definitely didn't get
anywhere further than that
if I even got that far.
But, um, but, like,
every time I would kind of come up to,
like, okay, I'm in, like,
a new section, there's a new boss here
or something, I would be,
I would be getting, I would be getting
my ass kicked, like,
and then I would grind a little bit,
I would get some,
some new equipment and everything,
and then I'd be like, oh, okay, I'm doing really good now.
And then, 20 minutes later,
I'm getting my ass kicked again,
gotta grind a little more,
and got, so, like, I used,
you, more so than usual,
I was very aware of,
like, the scaling happening,
like, and feeling myself scale
to try and, uh,
match the enemies.
Like, it just, not in a bad or good way,
just, like, really noticeable
for some reason this time.
And I think this is mostly
historically accurate,
because I think, like, the whole,
like, romancing of the three kingdoms
situation was just three guys
in a bar fight,
and then it turned into,
uh, actual billions of people
fighting, um,
at the end of it. That's right,
yeah. That's, yeah,
that's what happened. It started out with,
yeah, it was like, it was like 200 people,
and then by the end,
yeah, it was the entire population
of the world. Several times the population
of the world, I think. Yeah,
at the time. And this is an early example
in the game, but just to show you
that the game isn't just,
uh, find the next fort,
fight all of the,
um, uh,
major characters there,
and, uh, now convert the fort
to part of your kingdom,
uh, to prove that there's actually
some kind of questing
going on.
Uh, very early on in the game,
you kind of hit,
like, a, well,
what do I do now moment?
And, uh, that certainly happened to me,
that's what made me pull up this guide,
and there's a character,
uh, Zhao Dong,
that you have to,
uh, recruit by running into him
in random battle,
and, uh, he's kind of like,
it's a, it's actually like a coin toss
thing, uh, the game decides on
probability of, like,
he, he isn't necessarily loyal
to his warlord,
so he might offer to join
your party, or he might run off,
and then you have to go find him again in a random
encounter, but if you do successfully
recruit him, you can go into this cave
where there is,
you know, like, the rival bandits are,
and if he's in your party,
they'll let you cross the water,
uh, which you obviously can't do
with any kind of item or anything otherwise,
but he needs to be in your party
as well, and so that becomes,
like, an interesting mechanic
of this game too,
where sometimes you need
the right person
in your,
uh, in your party
to move the story along,
but you'll just have to know
to have that person
in your party, like,
oh yeah, he was with. So there's no other way
around it? I,
I don't know if that's true
or not, I think that this might have
been, like, a backdoor thing,
I can't confirm or deny that
because that's just, I got stuck here
and that's what I did instead,
uh, Joe, I don't know if you did
something different. Uh,
no, I did, I think I just happened to,
it happened to work out for me,
so I didn't even realize
that that would be, like, uh,
something you got stuck on.
Right, yeah, so,
um, all that to say,
like, you know, that's something that does
happen in this game where you need,
you know, time and time again,
you need, like, the right kind of item
or the right person
in your party, uh,
even, like, who is in charge
of your party changes pretty early
in the game, uh,
with, um, is it Lube?
He leaves? Yeah,
he, like, leaves to take over the,
well, because he is promised,
like, to be the heir. At the end of the first chapter,
so that's pretty big,
right? Like, the guy who you probably were,
like, role-playing as,
is like, yeah, that's, that's me,
and everybody else is just
joining my party, it's like,
well, now I've left the party.
Yeah, but then he gives you,
the, he gives,
like, all his equipment to,
like, the guy that you recruit
immediately at that moment,
so it's kind of like he's just,
is replaced by,
like, a new... like, his son?
Was it? I don't remember.
I don't know. I don't know either,
because I can't track,
yeah, exactly, I can't track these names,
and it's totally our fault,
but I,
I couldn't do it. I just couldn't,
I didn't know who anybody was,
because I just don't know anything
about, uh, this story.
I'm just, uh... and that's what,
it does feel like, even with what you're mentioning
about, like, needing to have this person
in your party to progress
and things like that, it feels like
maybe, maybe the game can be
a little bit, uh,
accused of
requiring you
to sort of know the story
already. I mean,
like, some of the stuff,
it's like, maybe if I'm very familiar
with the Romance of the Three Kingdoms,
I'd be like, well, at this point,
I'm supposed to have this person
because I know that.
But, like, I don't know,
I guess it depends on,
and maybe I haven't
combed the game thoroughly enough
for, like, yeah,
like, I'm sure there's enough hints
from the NPCs and stuff,
like, in another JRPG.
That's entirely possible
because this is a game
that does give hints,
but what you were describing then,
obviously, I have not played the game
as much as you guys have,
but when you were describing
the situation of,
like, oh, you can go into the bandit camp
and you get free passage
across this thing, like,
that's really cool
if that's,
like, one way to do it.
Right. But if that's the only way
to do it, then that is some,
like, that's some Castlevania 2 stuff,
and I'm not really a big fan
of really obscure ways
to lock progression.
I am a fan
of really obscure ways
to sidestep
things you might think
are necessary,
like, sort of like an immersive sim
sort of thing, or,
like, a CRPG,
but no,
that kind of, my opinion flipped
on its head there. I think that can happen
in some regards
where, like,
the battles might be tougher
if you didn't take on
some of these guys
beforehand, like,
who is, like,
at the end of the chapter
and stuff. I don't want to say that
with 100% certainty,
but I do recall seeing that
in my guide of,
like, if you fought so-and-so earlier,
they won't be at this battle,
and I thought that was kind of cool,
too. Yeah.
Like, it's keeping track
of a lot of moving parts,
and, um,
we're just one more thing
to keep track of. There is a sequel
to this game,
uh, but it did not,
uh, come out,
uh, on the NES.
Kind of crazy that this one did,
right? Like, this, this feels like the kind of,
like, RPGs didn't sell well,
uh, back then,
and this is very Japanese
and, or Chinese.
I'll be honest,
this feels like such a game,
like, a type of game that we have not played,
and, because of it,
this, this week,
we, we've also been playing
one of our Bytes games,
and I kept thinking
this was the Bytes game,
because I was like, yeah, this didn't come out in the US,
because, like, US audiences don't play
this kind of game, and I'm like,
no, this isn't the Bytes game,
this is the regular game
for the regular podcast.
Um, so, yeah,
it's funny, because it is just,
it is a very unique experience
compared to really anything
we've played. Obviously,
you know, closer to some things
like Dragon Warrior
and stuff, but,
but it,
it definitely has
its own unique charm.
And the, uh,
just to close it up,
the other one
on the Famicom that we may explore
in a Nostalgia Bytes episode
for our Patreon members,
uh, that removed
the food management system,
so there's no, like,
rice to collect or anything,
uh, it kind of
made the
open world thing,
like, a little more linear,
so it's,
it's not, like,
on rails necessarily,
but there's less branching paths,
and, like, go anywhere you want
kind of thing, and more,
like, take down this,
then do this, then do that,
uh, but it, it's not all,
like, removing features,
there was also,
uh, the introduction of
formation tactics
in, in addition to,
uh, the magic system
that we had in this one,
now it's, like,
you know, put your,
uh, put your characters
in a specific order
for specific stat bonuses
or special effects
during battle,
uh, so I like that,
because that, that kind of plays into,
again, another thing that you would see
in the Koei games
of, like, what kind of,
uh, units you want to place
near each other and everything,
like, having that in an RPG
sounds cool and reminds me,
uh, a little bit,
like, what you would see on,
uh, the Super Nintendo,
not necessarily the Famicom.
And then when you say formation,
though, I mean, this is still,
like, a regular,
like, party,
like you would see on the screen
in the Earth, it's not like,
it's not like it's become,
like, a tactical RPG.
still, still just a,
yep, just the order that you want
them to be in. Doesn't formation affect
something in this game?
The formation in this game
affects, like, who takes more damage.
Yes. So theoretically,
you would think that you want
to put your strongest,
like, the ones with the most soldiers
up front,
but actually, because of the way
that the Power of Ten rule works,
you want to put those guys
in the back of the party
so that they're always dealing.
I do not do that. I always put my strongest
in the front. but it's true. So,
yeah, so, so wait,
why put them in the back?
Because then they're not
getting hurt as much
and they're still dealing
their max output of damage.
yeah. But,
yeah, it seems kind of broken.
Because I also was,
um, worrying more about,
like, anyone dying.
Because another thing to think about is,
like, if you have,
if you have five party members,
they're all kind of,
I mean, granted, they're not splitting
the damage equally
because more damage
is going to the people in the front
than in the back, but,
like, they are splitting
the damage. Once you have
three people left, now all that damage
is being split among three people.
Once you have two people left, so it's like,
when the more,
the fewer people you have left,
the more that those
people are taking damage.
Sounds really obvious
now when I say that out loud,
and of course, that's obviously the case
in any other RPG
ever with a party,
but, like, it's so much more
visible this time
because, like,
of the all-out feature
where you just, like, see it,
like, wow, everyone's health's
going down slowly. One person dies,
that's going down fast.
Two people die. It's like, oh my god,
my health is plummeting.
You know, it's like, it's just so much more
top of mind. There's a lot of,
yeah, positive feedback loops.
Yeah. So that's why I was always
trying to keep strongest
on top, so it's like,
he can take a bunch of hits,
whereas the weaker can't,
but, like, I'm trying to keep it
spread out, like,
keep everybody alive,
you know? And apparently,
Destiny of an Emperor
is very well regarded
in its fan community
to the point where they have their own
modding tool,
Destiny of an Editor,
where you can change
the stats of any
of these characters, change the names
of the characters, the maps,
the encounters, the graphics.
Apparently, there is an annual,
like, award for the best
new Destiny
of an Emperor hack,
so there's certainly
a community here
just like there is
for Tech Mobile.
Do you think there's a George Washington one?
Right? Where's the American
Revolution one? I'm sure that they're also,
yeah, they're changing, like,
the setting
in a lot of these,
too, if they're going to change the maps,
so maybe it already
exists, Joe. Check out the
Destiny of an Editor.
Oh, that's a look.
And we will look
into whether
Destiny of an Emperor
will be the next game
on the Essential Games
list. Right now,
Destiny of an Emperor
is giving me
more of, like,
you know, cult status
than it is
essential status.
I think this game
is, like,
really under the radar.
I had never heard of it.
It totally made me,
like, I wasn't playing it
early enough, and I was like,
shit, I gotta find some time
for this. Like, this is a different
kind of game than I thought
I was gonna be playing.
And over the course
of, like, the two weeks
that I was playing it,
it was something
that I both respected
but wanted a lot more
out of it than what it gave me.
I think what we have here
is kind of what I was
getting at in the body
of the episode where you can make
this game sound
like,
it's like a massive
open world,
three kingdoms,
unbelievable, 150 recruitable characters,
and you can do this
and you can do that
and you won't believe
what happens in chapter four
and it's like, you kind of do want
it to be that game
but ultimately it is just a little
too repetitive.
It almost reminds me
of, like, Dragon Warrior
where it's like, yeah, it's a totally
competent NES RPG,
beloved by many
but in today's time
it's a little
too, not stale
but it's just, it runs its,
it overstays
its welcome. There was a point
in this game early on
where I was like, oh, I can't wait
to, like, see how this ends
and then there was
a point where, like, I think I'm ready
to end it and to me
that's not a good sign
of an essential game
even though it laid down
so many cool features
for an RPG that just got me
thinking differently about, like,
what RPGs can be doing.
Like, I've never seen this
with the HP system
being also the number
of troops you have.
Like, it's more than just
flavor text.
It actually changes
how you do damage.
Like, that's awesome but it's not awesome
enough to just put
on the essential games list for reasons
like that. So for me,
it's a no. What about you,
Joe? I love a lot
of what this game
is doing. I really love
the recruiting
warlords as you go
and sort of building your party,
like, actually building
your party. You're not just
picking up you know,
six out of nine
possible party members.
Like, you're really building
like, pretty unique party
and you're changing
the way that the
world,
the overworld sort of works
with random encounters.
And the battle system
is pretty fun too.
I appreciate
the all-out feature
kind of speeding
things up. I mean, if that wasn't in it,
this game would be, you know,
200 hours long.
But, but yeah,
I think that,
like, I started with,
sort of echoing you,
Mike, I started with
this, like,
high level of excitement
and interest and,
like, a little bit of,
like, tediousness
or, like, to,
like, the tediousness.
And that kind of
bar graph reversed slowly
as I went. And I do think that,
like, I really,
really enjoyed
the combat and the boss battles
of this game, but I didn't enjoy them
as much as I was bored
from the rest of,
like, from the random encounters
as time went on. Now,
I didn't get, you know,
super far in this game either
and I have watched
some footage and it does seem,
like, really late in the game.
The battles start to get,
like, more strategic
or, like,
less than just
who has, who is stronger
in the sense where now,
like, the enemies are using
more tactics, they're healing,
they're using defensive things,
you got, they're trying to use things
to stop you from attacking
and on one hand,
I could see that making it even more tedious,
but on the other hand, I,
I would like to,
I wish I kind of had gotten
to a point where I felt that
and it didn't take so long
to get there so I can at least
feel like there's a little
more strategizing
once things started
to get stale. But I suspect that
that would get stale
eventually too. So,
I don't know. I think this is
absolute play it
for any, like,
JRPG fan,
but I, I can't put this
on the essential game list
for me. Sean?
Yeah. So,
this, this may sound
a little off topic,
but like the, I'd say the last few years
of this podcast,
no, yeah. The last few years
behind the scenes,
and maybe I've alluded
to it in prior episodes,
have kind of been me
falling out of love
with the JRPG
and,
and that shouldn't
really, like,
no game should bear
the brunt of that
change in,
uh, taste in opinion.
Um, but,
already, uh,
Destiny of an Emperor,
just because it's
leaning so much
into that,
that classic style,
it, it kind of got off
on the wrong foot for me.
I, however,
I can appreciate
all those things that you guys,
uh, pointed out as,
as new and unique
and something we
hadn't seen before,
and I do appreciate
that, and it,
it allowed me to,
like, to put a little bit
more time into it
than I really wanted,
originally wanted to,
um, because it,
that, that did pique my
interest. However,
it still is,
at its core, a very basic JRPG
where you have to open up the menu
to interact with anything,
and that just
really grinds my
gears in a way
that I forgot about
since Dragon Warrior,
um, so it,
it, the points get taken off for
that too, um,
but, yeah,
I, I like a lot
of the ideas and a lot of
the things on paper are really
cool. I didn't have
too much fun with this game,
um, so yeah,
it's not essential for me.
Sean, I like what you
brought up about the menuing,
because you're,
there's a, there is something
about, like, breaking immersion,
and nothing does that more than
when you walk
over a treasure
chest, instead of,
like, face it. Like it's just
painted on the floor.
Right, and you have to,
like, stand over it,
and then go into the menu,
and press the
check button
to check what's
inside of it, and it's like,
why couldn't it just be,
I'm facing this, I'm gonna press A,
and it's going to
tell me what I checked,
like, I understand we're
not there yet, but I hate when
we're not there yet, in these older games.
Are we there yet? See you next time.